Argentina in the past few minutes have
beaten France on penalties in Qatar to
win the World Cup final and what a final
it was Argentina have been leading it
soon ill for much of it following a
penalty from Lionel Messi then Di Maria
Angel Di Maria scored to make it soon
ill it had been that scoreline for some
time before Killian and Bape scored a
penalty for France in the 80th minute he
netted again in the 81st and these are
the scenes there this is
the uh Messi's strike there let us have
a look at Laurie's just couldn't uh get
it could he there we have live Shots
tonight from Buenos Aires where fans are
celebrating in their droves aren't they
just look at them a huge celebrations at
800 or 88
666 pounds watched one of the most
dramatic finals of the competition and
it was really evenly matched wasn't it
right to the end right to those
penalties so Killian and Bape I was
saying uh got three goals for France in
the 80th 81st minute and then deep into
extra time to give him a hat-trick and
that was the first time that somebody
scored a hat-trick since Jeff Hurst for
England back in
1966. this was really build us that the
two wonders two stars of both Argentina
and France Messi and mbappe and boy how
they performed but it wasn't to be for
France after losing a 4-2 on penalties
Argentina we're expecting they were they
thought they'd win their first trophy in
1986 and they did indeed and don't the
crowds there in the center of the
Argentinian Capital uh love it plenty of
tension for a while in France had
equalized that it went to extra time
and then
um high drama in that penalty shootout
and it came down to Argentina winning
4-2 on spot kicks let's get the thought
shall we have Luke Entwistle editor and
a French football expert at get French
Football news I have to say huge scenes
of celebration in Buenos Aires there but
it wasn't just to be for France
good evening no it wasn't to be that was
uh the definition I'd say of an
emotional rollercoaster of a game it
switched back and forth so many times
the the first half was but certainly the
worst we've seen France in the first
half the whole tournament uh and then in
the second half even until the 18th
minute they didn't really look in the
game they get back in the game through
and Nicholas mandira and then Ronaldo
colon Moana gets on the on the end of uh
on the end of a pass and then obviously
in Backpages the rest and back pay again
straight after and then even into extra
time it was backwards and forwards But
ultimately France don't defend the title
and Brazil are still the last side to to
win constituted World Cups when it came
to the 79th minute did you think it was
all over then
I think so and it looks as oh friendly
to have the answers to what Argentina
were posing them for for the first half
there was no real cohesion or coherence
in what France were trying to do and
that really spilled over into the second
half as well it was only those
substitutions and once they began to
take hold that we saw France get any
kind of grip on the game and then
Killian mbappe being the player that he
is he only needs a bit of a cider of
gold and he can put it away so I'd say
in the 79th minute uh French funds would
probably head to the exit it's not that
there were too many of them in uh in
Qatar there's a massive massive argency
in the fall and I think something like
55 000 that Argentina fans were packed
in only 6 000 France fans apparently
there were more Argentina Flags than
there were fans for supporting the blue
in in this game but it didn't look like
a likely route back into the game but
mbappe just has that that clutch
mentality in the key moments and then
obviously he did it again in the in
extra time the game looked finished
again they came back from the death
again and and then they just couldn't
quite get out of the line in the country
shoes out switched as you know it's it's
a 50 50 split
yeah but how well France performed once
I suppose they livened up they took time
didn't they but look at them Bape hat
trick there equaling uh feat of Jeff
Hurst and I mean this was always going
to be billed as uh Messi versus mbappe
wasn't it and and Bape delivered yeah I
mean this just felt like a game of
one-upmanship of the two greatest
players on the planet currently and uh
it's the Legacy player it's it's the
only messing in his final World Cup game
who who finally wins that trophy that's
eluded in his whole career and that
that's the Clean Sweep now uh obviously
the first half belonged to Lionel Messi
and then you just thought that then it
felt like a Changing of the Guard and
then it changes again when Messi gets
gets his second and then Becca gets his
hat trick as you say the first place
since 1966 to do so he's also now the
top scorer in World Cup final history
which is incredible for a 23 year old
plays he's already competing in his
second World Cup final
um but it wasn't to be his second World
Cup uh if he had won it he would have
been only one off Pele and he would have
been kind of full in emulating the great
pelly's footsteps if he had of won that
but it wasn't to be for him back here
today and the sports goes to Messi who
in his final game as we say is uh he's
now won everything so lots more to come
from how will French fans be feeling uh
tonight this obviously just happened so
pretty raw but uh can they be pleased
and how well I mean this game was one of
the most exciting finals in World Cup
history wasn't it certainly I mean this
is a classic if not one of the it's if
it's not the greatest World Cup final
it's it's certainly up there with the
great so it's a veritable classic but I
think that the expectations for France
gradually Rose throughout the tournament
so I think expectations despite the fact
they were defending Champions felt quite
low going into the tournament that's
largely due to huge injuries to to Karen
Ben's murders Pogba there's no no Paul
Pogba there's no one goal can't say
there's no preso campenbe there's so
many players missing from this side that
was so pivotal uh to the 2018 Victory so
I think the expectations alone as they
gradually Rose I think obviously the the
deflation that you'll feel from a defeat
and a defeat on penalties in World Cup
finals it's going to be very bitter but
I think that compared to what they set
themselves at the start of the campaign
I think they'd be very happy to to have
got this far in the tournament but when
you get so close to to getting your
hands on the trophy for the second time
in four years there's going to be a yeah
a massive deflation yeah can I ask where
your loyalty is like uh finally a French
supporter I mean you are a Brit
I uh I was supporting England in England
France but uh yeah I've been going
routing for France since so uh it's it's
disappointing to see them sitting for
the final hurdle but uh
that's how it is
all right thank you Luke for joining us
so good to see you thank you very much
uh we can bring in that straight away
our Sports correspondent Rob Harris who
is in Doha goodness uh uh words fail me
actually you know Argentina just did it
on penalties but how exciting it was
from the 80th minute onwards
what an epic final this was 12-year
Qatar waited to deliver this world cup
and it went right through to the
distance right the way through to
penalties we had both mbappy and messing
Messi's score in their first spot kicks
But ultimately those missed penalties
from France proved so costly with
Argentina prevailing 4-2-1 penalties and
just what a game it was France were
completely out of it it seemed when we
had Messi and Di Maria scoring those
goals which had put them into the tunnel
ascendancy then and Bape turned it
around with 10 minutes to go scoring the
penalty then equalizing to send the game
into extra time only after Lionel Messi
had been denied a chance to win it deep
the end of regular time when kugeleries
made a fingertip Stave and then in extra
time Messi thought he'd won it a close
range tap in but then still on Bape with
a hatchery the first hat trick scored by
a man in a World Cup final since 1966
and Jeff Hurst forced the game into a
penalty shootout but it proved a
shootout beyond the French they could
not defend their world title they could
not match Brazil 60 years ago in
becoming back-to-back men's Champions
and it means Argentina had their first
World Cup since 1986 Lionel Messi
finally has the one big prize that
alluded him to out a glittering career
having lost the 2014 final now in what
he said will be his final ever World Cup
match Lionel Messi is a world champion
as finals go you've seen that one or two
haven't you rob how does this rank
oh it truly goes down of one of the
greats the drama the tension the
excitement it looked like France were
completely out of it they turned it
around we thought perhaps the virus that
had been sweeping through their squad
might be something that had drain the
energy they're giving them no chance
they hadn't even had a shot on Target by
the time and Bape scored that penalty
with about 10 minutes to go and they
found a new lease alive which really
created this thrilling conclusion
sending it into extra time and then that
extra time drama and penalties are such
a cruel way it's often seen to settle a
match particularly to settle a final we
know as England fans how painful
penalties can be and for France they
really experience the agony of them with
those decisive kicks Miss allowing
Argentina to Prevail but what a moment
for Argentina when they've waited since
the air of Diego Maradona in 1986 to try
to win the World Cup for a third time
but here they are at the top of world
football again France just missing out
where and perhaps this was the World Cup
for them but they'd been denied by
injuries leading into this tournament
that Karen Benzema was ruled out during
the tournament and golicante couldn't
even travel here so perhaps to get this
far through to the final surprise so
many but for Argentina and for Lionel
Messi Messi was already confirms one of
the greats of all time this will just
confirm that status Messi completing the
set of major trophies sets him apart now
alongside the likes of Diego Maradona
and Pele and perhaps as we think about
his great rival in the current game
Cristiano Ronaldo perhaps we've seen the
last of him ever at a World Cup given
his performance and he'll never win a
World Cup but Lionel Messi would know
now will be a world champion in his
career
yeah and just very very briefly uh Rob
uh it has been a tournament hasn't it of
upsets and surprises
yeah let's remember how this tournament
began for Argentina one of the biggest
shocks potentially in World Cup history
they were beaten by Saudi Arabia and we
thought perhaps the end of the journey
for Argentina in this world cup might be
in the group stage but they've turned it
around just like they did they came back
tonight against France as well and for
Argentina just one of those upsets we've
seen the Run of Morocco will live long
in the memory hint beating Belgium Spain
and Portugal before being denied a trip
to this final by France and really the
Moroccan success helped them to reflect
This World Cup the first World Cup in
the Arab region and the fan base has
really energized this tournament giving
it a real Regional flavor we are 12
years since that vote that awarded Qatar
the World Cup one of the most
controversial decisions in football
history one that has deep ramifications
scandals controversies and
investigations running through the years
and potentially even nearly bringing
FIFA to its demise but this tournament
will go down is delivering some shocks
some classic matches and epic final but
still for many decades to come there'll
be questions about whether this
tournament should even have ever been in
Qatar the suffering of Migrant workers
to deliver the World Cup discrimination
some fans faced here LGBT fans who had
things like rainbow Flags taken off them
but for Qatar they say it has been
transformative they have changed laws
they have adapted to the Western culture
to welcome fans from all across the
world to this world cup and it's the
World Cup that took football to New
Frontiers bringing football to the
Middle East for the first time with a
global event as people would say making
football truly Global but there will
always be those questions about this
tournament the deaths more than 400
migrant workers dying in the
construction of the 200 billion pound
project to deliver this world cup and
the transformation of Qatar but on the
pitch they'll be celebrating the
football success and that is success for
Argentina finally being world champions
again for the first time since 1986 and
Lionel Messi finally getting a chance to
pick up the World Cup